Ah, donc tu taffes toujours ici toi, en fait !
Julia ?
Tu vas bosser sur le plateau, là ?
Ouais, Régis est malade, c'est moi ton
assistante réal aujourd'hui.
Après t'inquiètes pas, il va revenir, tu me verras plus.
Mais moi, en tout cas, ça me fait plaisir de te revoir.
Ok, ce moment est gênant. T'es prêt ?
- Euh, oui oui, je termine juste ça, j'arrive.
- Ok, dépêche-toi.
Vous êtes comment sur le makeup, là ? Parce que...
Concentre-toi. Vas-y, fais-toi équiper...
Je peux me faire équiper et te parler en même temps, je peux
faire les deux chose en même temps-
- Oh !
- Fais attention à toi !
Attend, tu te crois où là ?
- Tu ne bouges pas !
- Chris, qu'est-ce que tu nous fait là, calme-toi !
- Chris.
- Bon écoutez, ça va être très simple,
tout le monde me connaît ici.
Je suis tout sauf méchant, et je veux buter personne, alors
on va faire comme tous les jours.
Vous, vous allez lancer le JT comme si de rien n'était,
et moi je vais passer un message en direct, tout simplement.
Ça serait quand même dommage
que quelqu'un se prenne une balle bêtement, non ?
- Ouais, là ça serait dommage.
- Toi, tu fais ce que je te dis !
Je FAIS ce que tu- j'ai rien fait !
Chris, tu fais quoi là ?
Tu sais quoi ? Je me bouges le cul, justement.
C'est pas ton concept préféré, ça ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ici ?
Mais c'est quoi ce délire, là ?
Lance l'émission, toi !
Mais c'est qui ce gars-là ?
C'est notre ingé son, madame.
- Chris, c'est Chris.
- Bouge pas.
N'importe quoi ! Qu'est-ce qu'il veut lui, encore ?
Je veux juste passer un message.
Allez, on se magne là !
Et c'est quoi, votre message ?
Si notre gouvernement, notre monde,
ne prend pas des mesures drastiques,
notre civilisation court à sa perte !
Vous êtes tous complices de ça, vous me dégoûtez !
Ah ouais, donc on est sur un
message écolo, c'est hyper original.
- Assieds-toi !
- Ça va, je m'assois !
- Tu fais juste ce que je te dis !
- Je fais ce que tu dis.
- Tais-toi.
- Bon, déjà, si on veut trouver une solution,
je propose qu'on arrête de le prendre de haut.
- Attends, le mec me braque, je...
- Tu te tais !
- Ok, ok, ça va !
- Ferme-là.
Chris... écoute-moi, je suis d'accord avec toi.
Mais, tu penses pas que le monde serait mieux sans nous ?
Quoi ?
La Terre elle à quoi, 4 milliards et demi d'années ?
Et nous, en à peine un siècle d'industrialisation,
on a tout niqué, c'est bien ça ?
Mais qu'est-ce que tu veux faire ?
On est tous victimes là-dedans.
La planète, elle s'en tirera très bien sans nous.
Faut arrêter d'être des enfants.
Moi j'ai arrêté, j'ai jeté ma cape.
On est pas des superhéros.
Moi j'en peux plus de me sentir
démuni face à tout ça, je me dégoûte !
Et quitte à avoir envie de mourir tous les jours,
autant que ce soit pour le bien commun.
Et ouais Dounia, c'est là où
j'en suis dans ma vie, maintenant.
Ben vas-y, dis-le, dis-le !
Je fais pitié, hein ?
C'est ça, ma réalité.
Ok, donc, Catherine, en gros
on embauche que des fous ici, c'est ça ?
Oooh !
Ah !
-  Aaah, fils de pute !
- Allez, on lance l'émission maintenant !
- Recule, toi !
- Merde !
- Aidez-moi là, putain !
- Recule ! Lancez l'émission !
- Arnaud ! Merde...
- Aidez-moi, putain...
Mais laisse-nous le soigner, Chris !
- Olivier, fais pas le con !
- Mais enfin, il pisse le sang !
Mais merde, je lui ai juste tiré dans la jambe, c'est rien !
Bon, allez, c'est bon, lancez l'émission.
- Allez, dépêchez-vous.
- Oui, ok, ok,
on va y aller, ok.
S'il vous plaît, en régie ? S'il vous plaît...
Ok, on va envoyer, maintenant !
C'est parti, 3, 2, 1...
Go.
Bonjour le monde !
Eh oui, vous êtes en train
d'assister à un message pas comme les autres.
Aujourd'hui, Monsieur Personne à la parole.
En exclusivité, pour une fois,
vous allez pouvoir avoir une version des news
sans réécriture et sans transformation.
Nous sommes pareil au fond, je le sais.
Nous vivons sans savoir quoi faire, ni comment.
Et moi, aujourd'hui,
je désespère.
Je désespère de voir nos dirigeants participer à
l'effondrement de notre civilisation.
Et tout ça pour quelques privilèges !
On vous parle de réchauffement climatique,
on vous parle dépuisement de ressources,
de la crise économique,
Et tout ça, c'est votre faute. Ouais.
"Notre faute ?
Pourquoi ?
Ah !
Parce qu'on prend des douches trop longues.
Parce qu'on met du papier
dans la poubelle verte et pas jaune."
Et pendant qu'on est là à discuter bien
sagement d'écologie pour se donner bonne conscience,
il y a deux mille tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium
qui ont pété à l'autre bout du monde,
faisant des centaines de morts et des dizaines de blessés !
Et si nous étions les prochaines victimes ?
Victimes de notre propre sort !
Aujourd'hui, je suis écœuré.
Je suis écœuré, de ne pouvoir voir un monde
dans lequel on prendra soin de son prochain,
où le mot "exploitation" n'existe plus !
Alors réveillez-vous, là, réveillez-vous !
Parce que derrière nos t-shirts à
40 euros se cachent des esclaves modernes.
C'est triste, hein ?
Mais moi, dans le fond, je l'aime ce monde.
Avec vous on pourra tout changer.
Et ensemble, nous ferons honneur à ce que nous sommes.
Et à l'humanité.
Allez, bouge.
Allez !
Bravo les gars.
Et stop.
C'est bon, on a pu éviter le pire.
C'est bon, le message n'est pas passé ?
Oui, tous les médias ont été bloqués.
- Parfait.
- Quoi ?
- Et le live ?
- Non,
c'est comme si rien n'avais jamais existé.
Bravo, vous avez été très courageuse.
Ça va monsieur ?
Pardon mademoiselle.